mes chers collègues notre commission
d'enquête poursuit ses travaux ce matin
pour trois auditions qui seront comme
c'est le principe que nous avons retenu
diffusés en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale nous serons donc
ensemble jusqu'aux alentours de 11h je
vous remercie monsieur le Préfet
l'allemand d'avoir accepté de venir
échanger avec notre commission vous vous
doutez que ce ne sont pas vos actuels
fonctions de secrétaire général de la
mer qui ont motivé votre invitation mais
bien l'expérience accumulée au cours de
votre carrière dans le corps préfectoral
qui vous a particulièrement confronté à
la question des violences en marge des
manifestations bien sûr tout le monde se
souvient que vous avez été préfet de
police de Paris mais vous avez également
officier comme préfet de laine de la
Saône-et-Loire du Calvados et de la
Gironde je le souligne à dessin car
notre travail dépasse le seul cadre
parisien vos fonctions dans les
départements que je viens de citer qui
suppose un maintien de qui n'est pas
identique on peut l'imaginer à celui de
la capitale ont certainement nourri des
réflexions qui ne manqueront pas
d'intérêt pour les membres de la
commission un questionnaire vous a
préalablement été transmis par notre
rapporteur monsieur Florent Boudier
évidemment dans l'entretien de ce matin
l'ensemble des questions ne sont sans
doute pas abordées donc si vous pouvez
dans un second temps nous transmettre
les réponses écrites pour compléter par
rapport à l'audition vous savez quel est
le sujet qui nous réunit nous étudions
les manifestations du printemps tant à
Paris qu'ailleurs en France et entre
autres aussi en milieu rural l'objectif
pour la Commission est double d'abord
comprendre la logique des groupuscules
et des auteurs de violence ensuite
examiner le déroulement des
manifestations pour déterminer si des
améliorations sont possibles ou des
correctifs souhaitables
justement des correctifs et des
ajustements dans les principes du
maintien de l'ordre il y en avait eu
plusieurs à la suite de l'épisode des
gilets jaunes et il n'est pas inutile de
se retourner vers le passé récent pour
évaluer ses évolutions pour estimer si
elles ont répondu aux attentes ou si
elles sont impuissantes face à de
nouvelles configurations et de nouvelles
formes de violence nous sommes
évidemment impatients d'échanger avec
vous avant de vous faire prêter serment
et de passer la parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur il me revient cependant de
poser les deux premières questions qui
ont vocation introduire nos débats en
premier lieu à la lumière de votre
expérience préfectorale et de
l'actualité diriez-vous que le régime
juridique actuel des manifestations
permet un bon équilibre entre d'une part
le respect des droits fondamentaux et
d'autre part le maintien de l'ordre
public le principe déclaratif conduite à
une tripartition entre les cortèges
déclarés les Cort spontané et les
cortèges interdits espertinents et
éléments importants est-ce appliqué de
la même façon sur l'ensemble du
territoire national et en second lieu le
préfet est au confluent de tous les
acteurs de la manifestation
organisateurs services de renseignement
unité de maintien de l'ordre
gouvernement autorité judiciaire
juridiction administrative
diriez-vous que cette position permet
d'agir efficacement sous le double
prisme à nouveau de l'ordre public et
des droits fondamentaux ou certaines
améliorations vous semblent-elles
nécessaires
Monsieur le Secrétaire général avant de
vous donner la parole et en application
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité je vous
prie de lever la main droite et de dire
je le jure après avoir activé votre
micro et je demanderai à Monsieur Piguet
de faire la même chose si un moment ou
un autre il intervient mais sur
l'Allemand je vous laisse procéder en
premier
je vous en remercie donc sans tarder je
vous passe la parole
je répondrai bien évidemment avec le
plus grand plaisir aux questions qui me
seront posées par les membres de la
commission peut-être pour justement vous
répondre directement
vous avez évoqué ma carrière je dois
vous dire que préfet de police n'est pas
tout à fait
un préfet de droit commun il est si
j'ose dire une autorité de police et il
n'est d'ailleurs pas que préfet de
police de Paris mais de l'agglomération
parisienne voilà juste pour un peu
préciser les choses et donc sur le
régime actuel son équilibre moi je pense
que le dispositif est assez satisfaisant
mais comme d'habitude dans notre droit
nous avons tout le problème de la
sanction
est-elle par contre au niveau mais le
régime déclaratif le droit de manifester
tout ça fonctionne à peu près
correctement la difficulté porte sur ce
justement qui ne le respectent pas et
qui en fait sont dans une dans un grand
nombre de cas dans une relative impunité
donc ça interroge mais comme toute une
série de sujets dans notre société sur
l'impunité en la matière le sur le
préfet lui-même pour essayer également
de faire très court voilà aussi je pense
qu'on a atteint un équilibre assez
satisfaisant c'est pour ça que je
mettais un peu de côté les fonctions de
préfet de police par rapport aux autres
fonctions de préfet de département ou de
région qui sont un peu différentes mais
je vais me référer à mon expérience de
nouvelles Aquitaine et à la partie gilet
jaune de Bordeaux que j'ai pu connaître
moi je trouve que les choses en termes
de chaîne ne commandement de capacité
juridique fonctionne plutôt bien
il y a une intégration des forces de
sécurité l'extérieur autour du préfet
qui m'a toujours semblé
satisfaisante les situations
exceptionnelles relèvent révèlent en
fait la solidité de notre dispositif je
crois que c'est ce qui vient d'être
éprouvé au travers des violences
urbaines en province nous avons un
dispositif solide qui date finalement du
consulat mais qui dans matière de
capacité régalienne peut justement
surmonter des situations très
exceptionnelles voilà ce que je pouvais
dire au préalable monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup sur le secrétaire général
alors évidemment lorsque l'on regarde le
déroulement d'un certain nombre de de
manifestations vous le disiez vous-même
ce qui semble parfois posé problème et
qui est qui est aussi repris par un
certain nombre de personnes que nous
avons auditionnées et vous avez utilisé
ce terme il y a quelques instants la
question de la relative impunité est-ce
que il y a là nécessité de faire évoluer
le dispositif législatif
la difficulté de faire respecter un
système s'il n'y a pas de sanction
repose sur l'adhésion de nos concitoyens
à des valeurs communes et donc la
question qui se pose c'est ce que c'est
adhésion est suffisante pour que par
exemple pendant les manifestations les
bons citoyens dénoncent ce qui cassent
empêche de manifester dans la limite de
leur possibilité ceux qui n'ont pas
déclaré dès lors que vous avez la
réponse à cette question je crois qu'on
peut en déduire un certain nombre de
choses non
il arrive quand même assez fréquemment
qu'il n'y ait pas de déclaration dans
les manifestations qu'il y ait des
cortèges sauvages c'est-à-dire des gens
qui quittent le cheminement de la
manifestation telle qu'il était prévu
avec dès le début l'intention de le
faire ou même qui se rassemblent en
début de cortège et qui empêche la
manifestation de se dérouler ce qu'on
appelle les pré-cortèges les nébuleuses
qui se créent en début de cortège et
donc
c'est vrai qu'on peut faire tout ça sans
finalement le moindre risque juridique à
part si on est
identifié comme étant l'organisateur
mais elle est identifié l'organisateur
d'un cortège sauvage surtout avec les
réseaux aujourd'hui du temps de l'empire
du premier ou deux secondes vous aviez
effectivement des organisations qui
derrière
organiser les choses si j'ose dire et
avec des chefs des sous-chefs etc
aujourd'hui les réseaux vous donnent une
transversalité totale de la façon dont
ça fonctionne donc dès lors voyez bien
que notre droit qui est adapté à un
organisateur enfin qui vise un
organisateur qui vise donc
désorganisation face à la transversalité
de ce que sont l'organisation en réseau
et je crains que les dernières violences
urbaines les démontrées me semble
effectivement inadaptée
je vous remercie je vais passer la
parole à Monsieur le Rapporteur oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Secrétaire général Monsieur le Préfet
merci d'avoir accepté le cette
convocation devant la commission
d'enquête je rappelle parce que nous
avons eu la semaine dernière des
personnes auditionnés qui s'étonnaient
de principalement d'une convocation dans
une commission d'enquête c'est en effet
une convocation et j'indiquais
d'ailleurs que les préfets anciens
préfets étaient eux-mêmes convoqué merci
première question
à la fois passage à Bordeaux nouvelle
Aquitaine puis ici à Paris
l'évolution du profil des individus
groupuscules violents constaté entre la
séquence gilet jaune la séquence que
vous avez vu ensuite à traiter ici sur
la plaque parisienne quels sont les
évolutions que vous avez constatées dans
le profil la diversité
des individus et groupes violents
concernés
ça ça me paraît important que nous ayons
ce film long l'analyse au terme de la
commission d'enquête deuxième question
vous êtes à l'origine du de l'évolution
du schéma national de maintien de
l'ordre
quels sont les éléments qui à l'époque
ont suggéré de votre part d'impulser
cette transformation qui aboutit me
semble-t-il après
vos fonctions si je ne trompe pas de
semble-t-il quelles sont les éléments
qui ont poussé à cette évolution et
quels sont les points stratégiques que
vous souhaitiez consolider ou
transformer à travers cette évolution
surface tout de suite la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur
parce que j'ai pu constater mais ça
n'est qu'un constat personnel donc il
n'a pas vocation à être généralisée
c'est effectivement sur les individus
qui se radicalisaient
le fait au moment des gilets jaunes
qu'on avait plus exactement le même
profil c'est-à-dire le profil en quelque
sorte historique du Black Bloc tel qu'il
résulte du milieu des années 2010 était
plutôt un jeune très politisé les
ultra-violents qu'on a vu monter avec
les gilets jaunes c'est à dire les
gilets jaunes radicalisés étaient des
gilets jaunes c'est à dire des personnes
éventuellement plus âgées et qui
n'avaient pas de de
démarches idéologique très structurée
c'est à dire une culture révolutionnaire
classique
tel qu'elle peut tourner en rhétorique
certains dans certains groupuscules
d'extrême gauche
voilà donc oui la constitution d'un
black bloc parce que en quelque sorte à
partir du moment il identifie pas les
gens qui a une unité d'habillement la
couleur noire etc révèle sous les
masques des personnalités assez
différentes moi ce qui m'a toujours
frappé dans les manifestations de gilets
jaunes qu'elle soit à Bordeaux ou à
Paris c'est qu'en fait elle ne durerait
pas véritablement la nuit
exceptionnellement ça m'arrivait jusqu'à
21h à Paris tout état de cause à
Bordeaux ça s'arrêtait un petit peu plus
tôt parce qu'on sent bien que les gens
rentrent chez eux et qu'ils ont un
certain nombre de tâches à faire
éventuellement d'aller chercher les
enfants ou de promener le chien donc
vous voyez c'est
l'irruption d'une classe moyenne dans
des actes de violence qui du coup se
retrouve dans des horaires de
manifestation encore une fois ce que je
vous dis est très personnel est-ce que
vous pouvez parler plus près du micro
pour que je vous entende mieux notamment
sur sur l'enregistrement je vous
remercie
bon je ne suis pas monsieur le
rapporteur à l'origine du schéma
national c'est les ministres de
l'Intérieur successifs et l'actuel qui
l'a conclu qui en sont les acteurs
simplement je suis un des
interlocuteurs de la discussion qui a
été dans les médias relatés sur mise à
distance
proximité du maintien de l'ordre qui est
un débat un peu étonnant mais qui est
vécu qui a été vécu comme ça
il est nécessaire que les forces de
sécurité intérieure les dispositifs
s'adaptent à la réalité de ce que sont
les manifestations très longtemps on n'a
pas eu besoin de se rapprocher des
manifestations ou du moins pas en cas de
volonté de dissolution uniquement et la
nature même des manifestants à partir du
milieu des années 2010 a complètement
changé ou nécessité de changer cette
approche et c'est vrai que j'ai proposé
d'être beaucoup plus au contact
être plus au contact je ne signale
d'ailleurs à la Commission à comme
conséquence de tirer infiniment moins ou
LBD parce que là aussi j'ai lu toute une
série de choses sur l'utilisation des
LBD mais quand je suis parti de la
préfecture de police on tirait très peu
au LBD alors que je rappelle en décembre
2018 sur une manifestation il y a eu
plus de 1000 tirs sur les manifestations
moi lorsque j'ai terminé si on tournait
à une centaine de tirs une cinquantaine
c'était vraiment le maximum parce que la
proximité justement évite l'utilisation
d'armes intermédiaires constituée sur la
distance je me permets vraiment
d'insister là dessus et donc après le
schéma national de maintien de l'ordre
ne porte pas de doctrine très précisant
la matière mais il évoque simplement la
nécessité de s'adapter et d'ailleurs je
note que mon successeur qui est un
remarquable préfet de police
applique finalement des des justement ce
schéma
exactement dans le même esprit en
fonction de la nature de la menace on se
rapproche on s'éloigne mais il y a pas
si vous voulez dans le schéma national
de maintien de l'ordre d'évidence
doctrinal aussi structurée encore une
fois faut savoir faire preuve
d'adaptation
considérer qu'on peut gérer aujourd'hui
les manifestations telles qu'on les
gérait au lendemain de la deuxième
guerre mondiale ou le début de la 5e
République serait absurde parce que tout
simplement nous concitoyens ont changé
ils ne sont plus les mêmes la façon de
manifester n'est plus la même
regardez les images de manifestations
des années des années 60 ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes parce qu'il y avait
des grandes organisations constituées
qui elles-mêmes assurée le
avec leur service d'ordre la sécurité
des dispositifs moi je me suis retrouvé
dans la situation très paradoxale
d'être le principal organisateur de
manifestations pendant ma période
préférée de police puisqu'il n'y avait
plus de services d'ordre du moins sur
les gens qui à l'époque déclaré des
manifestations il ne s'en sentait plus
la responsabilité ils avaient plus ils
n'avait plus la capacité de les
organiser c'est à dire que nous police
étions en train de les encadrer par
défaut de leur capacité à le faire alors
que c'était pas du temps de ce que
j'appelle les grandes organisations
syndicales ou politiques véritablement
la façon dont se passait les choses donc
la transformation de ce que sont nos
concitoyens un flux forcément sur la
transformation de la méthode du maintien
de l'ordre
merci beaucoup
je me tourne vers les collègues qui
souhaitent oui monsieur je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur Monsieur le Préfet merci pour
pour vos propos alors moi j'avais une
question sur le maintien de l'ordre
est-ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
par rapport en fait à ce qui s'est passé
avec les gilets jaunes vous savez qu'il
y a eu
en fait la loi prévoit déjà de
condamner l'attroupement
avec le 431-3 du code pénal donc un trop
point sur la voie publique susceptible
de troubler de public est-ce que vous
pensez justement qu'aujourd'hui on
devrait avoir une capacité
d'intervention beaucoup plus rapide
c'est à dire que
nous avons des individus qui arrivent
qui commence à à se regrouper avec
peut-être des intentions mal venues et
il y a toujours un temps de latence
c'est à dire qu'on se dit bon peut-être
que ils vont finir par se disperser et
on voit qu'au final pas du tout donc
est-ce que vous pensez que justement ça
peut-être été
une alors peut-être pas une erreur mais
est-ce que ça devrait être un axe
d'amélioration pour justement essayer
d'intervenir beaucoup plus rapidement
sur des individus qui seraient qui
seraient voilà présent sur la voie
publique
est-ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
justement on devrait les forces de
l'ordre devrait intervenir beaucoup plus
rapidement
pour pouvoir mettre fin à cette
attroupement merci
ce secrétaire général je vous en prie
oui mais je partage monsieur le député
la nécessité d'intervention rapide c'est
pour ça que j'ai été à l'origine de la
création des des braves-motos
ça m'a été reproché parce qu'il faut des
vecteurs c'est-à-dire des moyens
d'arriver sur des manifestations
irrégulières ou régulières d'ailleurs en
cas de troubles de façon extrêmement
rapide quand on a 30 kg sur le dos on
court infiniment moins vite qu'un garçon
avec des baskets ou un garçon ou une
fille d'ailleurs avec des baskets et
donc faut se rendre compte de cette
réalité là faire débarquer une unité
enfin une compagnie ou un escadron de
CRS de ces camions après leur transport
c'est du temps c'est normal un
déploiement de 80 fonctionnaires aux
militaires durent un certain nombre de
minutes donc il faut avoir des vecteurs
de transport extrêmement rapide et
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que circuler dans
Paris nécessite de ne pas le faire en
quatre roues et donc vous voyez bien que
l'aménagement urbain est aussi
un élément de paix public et d'ailleurs
je suis suffit de se référer au baron
Haussmann ce que je dis n'est pas très
très nouveau mais dès lors qu'on réduit
l'espace de circulation on permet aussi
que se glisse dans la ville des
manifestations qui sont plus ou moins
régulières parce que elles sont
possibles dès lors
tout est dans tout est réciproquement si
je peux me permettre cette citation oui
alors après vous faites sans doute
référence j'imagine à l'interdiction
préalable d'un certain nombre de
manifestants conseils constitutionnels
etc et c'est vrai qu'il est dommage que
l'outil juridique qui est permis dans
les stades ne soient pas dans les
manifestations mais mieux que moi vous
connaissez le sujet est-ce qu'il y a des
possibilités d'évolution juridique qui
permettraient de le faire à mon avis ça
serait souhaitable mais je dépasse ma
condition en le suggérant
mais il faut avoir quand même conscience
de la limite d'un tel dispositif si
jamais il existait un jour par
définition de Black Bloc est très
difficile à identifier
par construction puisque c'est fait pour
ça un black
et donc
[Musique]
il faut quand même en termes de de trois
publics de défense des libertés
individuelles avoir suffisamment
d'éléments pour l'interdiction un
supporter sportif c'est beaucoup plus
facile à tracer et c'est beaucoup plus
simple de motiver l'interdiction dans ce
cas-là ça serait compliqué surtout que
dès lors que vous identifiez un black
bloc un bloc vous voyez bien que il y a
une pénalisation je voudrais me
permettre d'ailleurs de faire une petite
incidence sur la pénalisation on est
aujourd'hui dans un dispositif où il y a
une demande de pénalisation de la
manifestation c'est assez nouveau
j'allais dire de mon temps mais quand
j'étais jeune c'est-à-dire avant la
chute du Mur les choses ne
fonctionnaient pas du tout comme ça
l'essentiel de l'action de police était
de mettre fin à la manifestation qui
posait des problèmes et personne n'était
dans l'idée
d'interpeller et de présenter devant le
juge les gens qui cassaient etc donc
qui a atteint l'ensemble des sphères de
la société qui maintenant concerne le
droit de manifester tout simplement
parce que il y a une volonté
populaire sociale et que le juge veut
s'en mêler conditionne assez fortement
l'action des services de police et quand
vous interpellez un quelqu'un qui a
cassé ça peut servir de motivation plus
tard pour l'interdire de manifester mais
ce qui compte c'est de pénaliser de le
présenter un juge donc je
pense qu'il y a enfin j'ai une véritable
interrogation sur cette évolution de la
pénalisation du droit de manifester
quand je dis pénalisation du droit de
manifester attention pour être
parfaitement clair je ne veux pas dire
par là qu'il faut pénaliser le droit de
manifester mais qu'on fait intervenir le
juge dans la sanction de ceux qui ne
respectent pas justement ce droit de
manifester et encore une fois c'est un
phénomène récent qui date du milieu des
années 2000 qui oblige les policiers et
les gendarmes à
créer
tout un dispositif de PV
de façon d'apporter la preuve
qui est assez lourd de garde à vue de
noria pour emmener les gens en garde à
vue dans les différents endroits qui
sont prévus de permanence des parquets
pour suivre ensuite les garde-à-vis tout
ça n'existait pas il y a une vingtaine
d'années tout ça n'existait absolument
pas voilà donc oui mais que vous
proposez face que vous évoquez rejoint
mon propos préalable oui moi je crois
qu'il faut effectivement qu'il y a un
peu plus de sanctions contre ceux qui ne
respectent pas la règle du jeu
collective
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Secrétaire
général je voudrais qu'on revienne
justement sur sur ce point dans
l'ouvrage que vous avez publié il y a
quelques mois intitulé l'ordre
nécessaire vous avez une partie qui est
consacrée aux obstacles qui sont
aujourd'hui rencontrés par le mise en
oeuvre du maintien de l'ordre et vous
avez un passage où vous évoquez le fait
que le dispositif de maintien de l'ordre
au moment des gilets jaunes était trop
statique vous l'avez un peu évoqué ainsi
d'amment en disant que vous aviez
cherché à introduire des éléments de
mobilité est-ce que vous pourriez nous
en dire un petit peu plus et sur comment
dire ce retour d'expérience quels sont
un petit peu les recommandations que
l'on peut faire par rapport par rapport
au fait que ce maintien de l'ordre était
sans doute trop statique
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
d'avoir cité ce petit ouvrage sans
prétention
quand vous ne bougez pas les autres
bougent
subir un siège et la pire des situations
c'est malheureusement ce qui se passait
à Bordeaux puisque à Bordeaux j'ai passé
plusieurs mois à défendre la mairie
puisque je rappelle que les gilets
jaunes à Bordeaux ne t’attaquaient pas
la préfecture mais attaquer la mairie de
Bordeaux
et c'est très compliqué de défendre un
bâtiment de rester au même endroit parce
que vous concentrez beaucoup beaucoup de
violence à ce moment-là les gens veulent
absolument passer et vous êtes là
précisément pour les empêcher de passer
donc le choc est d'autant plus violent
qu'il y a cette opposition systématique
et comme il ne passe pas il se dirige
ailleurs
pour manifester leur colère par la
destruction et donc quand vous êtes en
situation de siège c'est à dire enfermé
dans cette espace que vous protégez vous
ne pouvez pas aller sur les arrières ou
les manifestants justement car c'est nos
concitoyens ne le comprennent pas en
ayant la pression qu'il y a une totale
impunité et en disant mais qu'est-ce que
vous faisiez ou vous étiez mais tout
simplement on était
on était un incapacité de sortir de
l'espace que nous avions nous-mêmes
créés donc c'est une situation qui est
nécessaire à mon avis d'éviter par
dessus tout et pour éviter ça il faut
être mobile si vous voulez c'est un
vieux principe stratégique qui existe
depuis la nuit des temps le meilleur
moyen de défendre une position c'est
justement de ne pas être dessus
je pourrais me référer à toute une série
d'auteurs en la matière donc il faut
être mobile il faut que là il y a une
capacité justement d'être
sur la périphérie des dispositifs parce
que c'est sur la périphérie des
dispositifs que se passe les
destructions les casses etc donc la
mobilité est absolument essentielle or
nous sommes dans nous étions dans un
système de de maintien de l'ordre qui
était basé
sur un rapport de force assez statique
c'est-à-dire les cortèges étaient
encadrés par des services d'ordre
qui faisait en quelque sorte la police
des cortèges et les fonctionnaires de
police ou les gendarmes mobiles étaient
sur un certain nombre d'endroits et dans
ce bon vieux temps finalement les
manifestations se passaient de la même
façon on savait à peu près ou aller se
faire les frottements il faisait partie
de la rhétorique du dispositif parce que
on avait l'habitude de ces
interlocuteurs et on savait grosso modo
comment se passait les choses il y a
quand même des exceptions à ce que je
dis si je le regarde de façon historique
c'est Mai 68 et avant bien évidemment
ce sont les événements
issus de la fin de la guerre d'Algérie
et notamment les manifestations
parisiennes qui étaient atypiques par
rapport à cette règle-là mais cette
règle-là était celle-là et donc la
conception des des maintiens de l'ordre
était basée sur ce positionnement
statique
et la composition même de nos
dispositifs de maintien de l'ordre est
basé sur ce dispositif statique
les compagnies et les escadrons ne se
sentent pas en dehors de la
demi-compagnie ou du demi escadron
c'est-à-dire
très rarement de la section pour la
compagnie c'est à dire de de la
vingtaine or dans des dispositifs de
cette nature et notamment sur les
effectifs préfecture de police
nous sommes descendus dans des
fractionnements au niveau du groupe
c'est à dire au niveau de 6 c'est
dangereux fractionné des effectifs à des
petits niveaux comme ça parce que bien
évidemment ils peuvent se faire attaquer
parce qu'ils ne sont pas suffisamment
nombreux mais c'est très efficace parce
que du coup vous étendez votre zone de
contrôle mais à charge pour vous d'être
en capacité de recomposer le collectif
qui est ainsi décomposé dans dans son
unité de base à 60 ou 80 donc voilà
c'est c'est pas simplement les vecteurs
c'est aussi la façon de conduire les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre bon
c'est vrai que c'est pas pratiqué pour
le moment se disent ce que j'explique
par les compagnies de CRS ni par les
escadron de gendarmes mobiles c'est
pratiqué par les compagnies
d'intervention de la préfecture de
police et ça nécessite une grande
maîtrise technique et une vision des des
choses
c'est pour ça que lorsque je suis devenu
préfet de police ma première
préoccupation ça a été de géolocaliser
les fonctionnaires
malheureusement quand je suis arrivé les
géoloc les géolocalisations n'existaient
pas elles existaient sur les véhicules
pas sur les individus et le dispositif
qui a été mis en place qui a été poussé
par les deux précédents ministres
l'actuel et son prédécesseur qui permet
aussi d'avoir des moyens de transmission
permet de géolocaliser les individus les
fonctionnaires et donc c'est beaucoup
plus efficace puisque vous savez à peu
près où ils sont rien n'est pires que de
perdre des gens
au sens de ne plus avoir de visibilité
sur eux je vais vous expliquer un peu
mieux ce que j'essaye de dire
une grosse manifestation à Paris
c'est un service d'ordre qui fait
entre 4000 et 6000 fonctionnaires c'est
un exercice qui se fait sur un terrain
dans le plus important des quatre trois
kilomètres sur 3 km la plupart du temps
ces 2 km sur 2 km donc parce que Paris
est tout petit contrairement aux cité
anglo-saxonne Paris je crois et la
cinquième ville la plus dense du monde
et on revient sur le baron Haussmann
l'espace vous contraint quand vous êtes
sur un tout petit espace dans de cette
nature dans une densité urbaine
extrêmement forte la difficulté c'est de
ne plus savoir où sont les effectifs et
de ne plus intervenir à bon escient et
de faire que des effectifs se retrouvent
au contact de manifestants violents sans
que vous l'ayez véritablement voulu ni
eux-mêmes d'où l'importance de la
géolocalisation de la vision globale
faut avoir une vision globale de ce que
de la façon dont s'organise le
dispositif à Paris on a par les caméras
mais c'est pour ça que les drones sont
assez essentiels parce que les drones
contrairement à ce qui racontait de
façon bébête par certains ne servent pas
à identifier les gens vous avez pas
besoin d'identifier les gens puisque
vous avez des caméras à Paris faudra
être particulièrement pervers pour aller
faire voler un drone pour identifier des
gens que vous voyez très très bien sur
le système de vidéo surveillance pour ça
que j'ai beaucoup regretté qu'on nous
est interrompu du jour au lendemain le
vol des drones et qu'il a fallu
pratiquement 3 ans pour faire voler des
drones alors que n'importe quel citoyen
français peut faire voler des drones la
situation jusqu'à y a encore quelques
semaines c'est que les seuls qui ne
pouvaient pas faire voler des drones
dans ce pays c'était la police et la
gendarmerie
je suis un peu agacé parce que j'ai
trouvé ça véritablement dommage et je ne
voyais pas véritablement été le problème
le drone vous permet d'avoir une vision
globale c'est-à-dire sur un sur
justement cet espace que ne vous permet
pas d'avoir les caméras puisqu'il
faudrait reconstituer l'image et ses
techniquesment impossible donc voilà
c'est extrêmement important d'avoir
cette vision globale etc pour envisager
un mouvement d'ensemble qui vous
permettent de préserver la manifestation
parce que
j'ai passé mon temps pendant trois ans
et demi à essayer de faire en sorte que
les manifestations déclarées arrivent à
leur point d'arriver puisque c'est ces
groupes de tête c'est nébuleuse qui
bloque les manifestations qui empêchent
le déroulement de la manifestation sont
le pire en matière démocratique de ce
qui peut arriver puisqu'on ne permet pas
l'expression de la contestation
l'expression régulière de la
contestation ce qui empêchait les
manifestations quand j'étais prête
police ce n'était pas les policiers les
gendarmes c'était les pré-cortèges c'est
manifestants ces groupuscules qui
n'avaient qu'une seule qu'un seul
objectif que les choses ne se passent
pas et du coup qu'elles dégénère parce
que quand vous avez un bouchon au début
de la manifestation d'abord ça énerve à
juste titre les manifestants qui
imaginent que ce sont des mesures de
police alors que ce sont des oppositions
et cela nécessite l'intervention de la
police et interrompt ou de la
gendarmerie et tenir en début de
manifestation sur ces pré-cortèges c'est
toujours extrêmement délicat j'ai bien
compris que les syndicats m'en avaient
beaucoup voulu du 1er mai 2019 et depuis
refusait de me rencontrer quand j'étais
prête police parce que ils ont pensé que
l'intervention que nous avions fait au
début de la manifestation du 1er mai
2019 qui avait
qui avait provoqué un peu de d'agitation
en début de cortège
était à l'origine des difficultés qui
avaient rencontré le carré de tête des
manifestants puisque je rappelle que ce
jour-là le secrétaire général de la CGT
a été évacué de son carré de tête
que FO est sorti de la manifestation moi
le sentiment que j'ai eu mais à vrai
dire parce que j'en avais une vision
globale c'est que ce sont plutôt des
gilets jaunes qui sont intervenus sur ce
cortège et nous n'avons fait que les
disperser en amont ce qui explique
ensuite que ces organisations syndicales
ont refusé de me rencontrer tout au long
de mon mandats de préfet de police je
l'ai assez profondément regretté j'ai
toute une série de lettres qui attestent
que je à chaque fois je leur proposais
cette rencontre et je me suis beaucoup
réjoui qu'à l'occasion de la nomination
de leur randonnieze et soit sorti de
cette posture et qu'ils aient enfin
accepté des contacts avec le préfet de
police c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et j'en suis véritablement très
satisfait
je vous remercie monsieur Lucas
merci monsieur le Président sur le
rapporteur Monsieur le Préfet ma
question change un peu de registre elle
vise à comprendre la conception
j'allais dire philosophique civique et
morale du maintien de l'ordre en France
pour éclairer notre travaux sur ce point
vous aviez déclaré une formule restée
célèbre en marge d'une manifestation à
une manifestante nous ne sommes pas
Madame dans le même camp c'était de
mémoire
vos propos vont me corrigerez évidemment
s'ils sont inexactes qui m'intéressent
dans cette formule c'est pas l'élément
j'allais dire de provocation médiatique
ou de réaction un peu un peu rapides à
chaud j'imagine que vous étiez dans une
journée particulièrement vive c'est ce
que cela peut révéler de la conception
du maintien de l'ordre et donc est-ce
que vous considérez et avec vous en
réalité est-ce que vos autorités de
tutelles à l'époque est-ce que votre
hiérarchie considérait considère d'après
vous encore aujourd'hui qu'il y a dans
les mobilisations sociales deux camps
face à face ce qui induit quand on a une
conception et un vocabulaire de cette
nature qui a finalement une désescalade
impossible parce qu'il y a des camps
c'est qu'on est dans une forme de
d'affrontement
et est-ce que vous considérez voilà
qu'on est dans cette dans cet état
d'esprit de quand qui se font face entre
les autorités de la République de qui
assure le maintien de l'ordre et les
manifestants et les manifestants
merci beaucoup monsieur secrétaire
général je vous repasse la parole merci
monsieur le président
je considère monsieur le député qu'à
l'intérieur de la République il n'y a
pas de camp mais qu'en dehors de la
République il y a des factieux qui
visent précisément à atteindre la
République et ce n'est pas nouveau qu'il
y ait des gens qui veulent tuer la
gueuse
et donc le moment que vous citez est un
moment avec une dame gilet jaune qui
alors que nous étions au lendemain de la
manifestation de novembre sur la Place
d'Italie alors que je venais devant le
monument aux morts de
l'armée
qui a débarqué en Italie
issu pour une partie de ces troupes du
Maghreb dans laquelle j'avais
effectivement dans cette armée un grand
oncle qui est tombé à monter casino
au sein d'un régiment de tirailleurs
algérien pour vous dire les choses
et que
cette dame
[Musique]
tiennent les propos qu'elle a tenu m'a
effectivement fait sortir de mes gonds
puisque je rappelle que la manifestation
avait détruit ce monument aux morts pour
en faire des projectiles et j'ai
considéré qu'effectivement quand on
faisait ça qu'on était plus dans le camp
de la République et je le redirai
exactement de la même façon alors après
il n'y en a rien en déduire d'autres que
ce que je vous dis bien évidemment le
droit de manifester fait partie de la
condition républicaine
il est absolument nécessaire il est
absolument fondamental et je crois avoir
expliqué précédemment que je m'étais
battu pour le faire respecter
que j'avais fait en sorte que les
manifestations se tiennent parce que des
gens voulaient justement qu'elle ne se
tiennent pas et donc vous voyez il n'y a
qu'un seul camp dans la République mais
malheureusement en périphérie de la
République nous guette comme disait
gramshi dans l'entre deux surgissent les
monstres
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Secrétaire
général monsieur Caron je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président
monsieur l'allemand nous sommes ici pour
comprendre la nature et les auteurs des
violences lors des manifestations
or votre gestion de l'ordre dans les
manifestations lorsque vous étiez préfet
de police a été largement remise en
cause décrié par de nombreux
observateurs
pour des choses clairement vous avez été
accusé d'avoir provoqué des violences
pendant les manifestations
notamment par l'intermédiaire des braves
m bravehem on la prend aujourd'hui
auquel appartenu le policier qui a tué
Naël un bout portant un Nanterre c'est
même policier a aussi appartenu autre
tristement célèbre c'est ainsi 93
compagnie déployant Seine-Saint-Denis
sous votre responsabilité dont les
membres ont été accusés certains
condamnés d'ailleurs de violence de vol
de mensonges de racisme accusés je le
précise par l'IGPN ensuite à de
nombreuses enquêtes donc le policier qui
a tunnel a appartenu au prav-mhem elle a
CSI 93 et on la prière il a été décoré
par vos soins mais revenons
à l'objet de cette commission et à votre
politique du maintien de l'ordre qui a
notamment été documentée par un article
de Mediapart une enquête de mars 2020 en
quête qui révèle que des hauts
responsables de la gendarmerie jugez vos
pratiques illégales
illégale notamment parce que vous
incitiez vos troupes à impacté je cite
c'est le terme les manifestants c'est à
dire en haut à rentrer dans le tas
donc ces responsables interrogés par les
enquêteurs de Mediapart dénoncent vos
directives ils disent notamment que vos
ordres étaient volontairement
dérogatoires au code de sécurité
intérieure notamment l'article R 211 13
selon lequel l'emploi de la force ne
doit avoir lieu qu'en cas d'absolu
nécessité et de manière proportionnée
l'enquête de Mediapart si plusieurs
témoignages et je vais me permettre d'en
lire un c'est le témoignage d'un CRS qui
encadrait des manifestants sur à ponton
quasiment 14 km de parcours et il dit
ceci lors d'une des manifestations
les Black Blocs ne branchez pas
ça a commencé à dégénérer quand les
Braves ont commencé à intervenir à la
fin de la manifestation la gare de Lyon
les braves se sont mis à foncer dans le
tas c'est incroyable de foncer dans le
tas comme ça alors que ce n'était pas
conflictuel il ajoute encore
parmi les manifestations il y avait des
cas sociaux ce sont ces mots j'ai
quasiment terminé mais il n'y avait
quasiment pas de casseurs et les Braves
ont chargé gratos et il conclut ce sont
encore ces mots la manière d'agir des
braves démontre soit un manque
d'expérience soit un manque de lucidité
soit je cite des ordres à la con
Monsieur Le Mans et je pose ma question
qu'est-ce que vous répondez
assez critique et mise par des membres
des forces de l'ordre pas par des
factieux pas par des gauchistes par des
membres des forces de l'ordre placées
sous vos ordres qui vous accusent très
clairement d'avoir été lorsque vous
étiez préfet de police à l'origine de
nombreuses violences constatées dans des
manifestations dont vous aviez la
responsabilité du bon déroulement
je vais évidemment passer la parole à
Monsieur le Secrétaire général
pour que vous puissiez évidemment
répondre petite précision tout de même
la commission d'enquête n'est pas une
commission d'enquête contre Monsieur
l'allemand que les choses soient bien
claires donc voilà mais je vous passez
évidemment la parole
monsieur le Président je suis là pour
répondre à toutes vos questions donc
monsieur le député vous noterez que je
ne vous appelle pas monsieur Caron
monsieur le député je suis navré mais je
ne lis pas médié à part donc je suis
bien peut-être
mais je j'attendrai avec plaisir que
vous me feriez l'abonnement ce qui me
permettra de découvrir cette littérature
dont effectivement
n'ont effectivement vous avez vous
parlez beaucoup mais pour moi ça n'est
pas le Journal officiel et ça n'est pas
la Bible donc je ne sais pas ce qui s'y
raconte mais vous m'interrogez sur
est-ce que j'essaye de reprendre votre
question indépendamment de la lecture de
Mediapart est-ce que j'ai eu des
reproches d'un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires aux militaires classés
sous mon autorité sur les dispositifs de
manifestations qui étaient mis en place
si je comprends bien c'est votre
question voire même des reproches de
laurier Archie organique en la matière
jamais jamais jamais jamais
et Dieu sait si pourtant je réunissais
l'ensemble des effectifs avant par
exemple manifestation ça se passe de la
façon suivante sur la préfecture de
police c'est que l'avant veille la
veille lorsque les dispositifs sont
compliqués
des commandants de compagnie ou d'unités
sont réunis s'agissant des gendarmes
puisque chaque structure c'est reste
gendarmes à un dispositif de
transmission des informations dans la
gendarmerie ça s'appelle le Gaumont qui
est placé auprès dans la salle de
commandement c'est à dire le chef du
dispositif gendarmerie si vous voulez le
chef du dispositif CRS qui sont dans la
salle de commandement qui suivent les
dispositifs jamais jamais aucun d'entre
eux ne m'a parlé de la moindre chose
jamais jamais et donc comme je non c'est
pas étonnant vous avez affaire à des
officiers vous avez affaire à des
fonctionnaires supérieurs républicains
honnêtes et qui n'auraient pas manqué
s'ils avaient eu des remarques d'en
faire part vous savez je ne suis pas
aussi méchant que vous le pensez je peux
tout à fait entendre
vous ne pensez pas je le note mais je ne
suis pas
ah non mais je ne parlais de ma
méchanceté monsieur le député
très bien je ne suis plutôt pas ni l'un
ni l'autre voilà donc je n'ai jamais eu
la moindre reproche et de leur part de
leur hiérarchie nationale non plus
jamais de ailleurs du côté du ministre
donc franchement je ne vois absolument
pas ce dont il s'agit
je peux me permettre un rebond je suis
très rapide vous aviez trois minutes
mais donc juste merci monsieur le
Président de votre largesse d'esprit
non mais c'est quand même étonnant parce
que il y a quand même il y a pas que
l'article de Mediapart j'aurais pu vous
en citer d'autres et je comprends que
vous n'y soyez pas
abonné parce que la ligne éditoriale ne
vous convient pas et c'est votre droit
le plus strict néanmoins vous avez quand
même lu un certain nombre d'articles qui
ont été écrits vous avez également
entendu des reproches récurrents qui
vous ont été faits sur votre politique
de maintien de l'ordre et vous ne
trouvez avec le recul aujourd'hui que ce
matin-là doit être irréprochable ou
qu'il n'a pas pu à un moment être à
l'origine je repose ma question très
clairement c'est très clair parce que
oui ou non cette politique qui
consistait effectivement à faire en
sorte que les forces de l'ordre chargent
sans raison alors qu'il n'y avait pas de
danger alors qu'il n'y avait pas
d'éléments perturbateurs de vente e vous
ne pensez pas aujourd'hui que cette
politique a causé des violences vous ne
la remettez toujours pas en cause
aujourd'hui vous puisque ce n'est
vraiment dans l'objet de notre
commission d'enquête c'est qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans des manifestations qui
tournent mal et ou des violences sont
observés comment elles arrivent comment
elles sont provoquées et donc pour faire
simple vous ne pensez toujours pas
aujourd'hui alors que c'est documenté
que votre politique de maintien a été à
l'origine de nombreuses violences
je vais évidemment demander à Monsieur
le Secrétaire général de répondre
simplement monsieur Caron je vous invite
comme vous vous invitiez monsieur
l'allemand à lire des articles de presse
je vous invite vraiment à lire le
l'ouvrage qui qui a été publié par
Monsieur l'allemand avec d'ailleurs un
journaliste Jean Jérôme bertolu sur
l'ordre nécessaire et vous verrez dans
cet ouvrage que en fait il y a une
analyse de la situation en parlant de ce
qui a évolué en termes de de
développement de la violence de des
problématiques enfin il y a un vrai
travail permet de le dire de
d'introspection qui qui a été réalisée
et puis il finit des améliorations
proposées donc si on parle de documents
à lire je vous assure ça
vaut la peine d'être conçu avec grand
plaisir monsieur le Président même si
votre invitation m'étonne parce qu'elle
ressemble presque à un plaidoyer
d'avocat en faveur de Monsieur
l'allemand et en tant que président je
suis un peu surpris non mais je crois
que en terme en terme d'avocat
vous vous savez à certains moments aussi
vous exprimer en tant qu'avocat et je
crois que pour moi-même
je vais laisser monsieur secrétaire
général répondent et puis ensuite je
vois que Monsieur Lucas souhaite
également intervenir donc je passerai la
parole à ce qu'il y aura d'autres
demandes d'intervention je me tourne
vers les collègues il y en aura pas donc
je vous remercie sur ce qui était Agena
je vous en prie
non mais effectivement n'étant pas
accusé je n'ai pas besoin d'avocat
c'est le député
quand on veut avoir ce type de
discussion il faut parler de cas
d'espèces mais Léon dit les racontars ce
qui aurait été porté à la connaissance
de telle ou tel dont on ne sait pas qui
c'est quand et où je vais vous dire ce
ne sont pas des éléments républicains ce
sont les bonnes vieilles méthodes de
dénonciation et de de
l'être anonyme de réseau excité moi je
veux non non mais ce qui sent ce que ce
qui sont à ce que c'est pas le journal
qui anime ce sont les citations les
références que s'est-il passé et où si
vous avez des cas d'espèces à ce moment
là moi je suis prêt à discuter des cas
d'espèces qui relevait des moments où
j'étais en fonction mais je vais pas
vous parler de façon générale encore une
fois de rumeurs de ragots de choses qui
ont été dites moi je vous donne des
éléments objectifs sur ce que j'ai fait
je vous ai dit je n'ai jamais eu de
remontée des effectifs placés sous mon
autorité
c'est pourtant précisément tout à
l'heure ce que vous avez cité c'est à
dire l'article de Mediapart c'est
compliqué de discuter avec vous c'est
qu'on met on pourrait peut-être en
parler en dehors de cet instant si vous
voulez moi je crois en parler
ce qui me pour essayer de vous répondre
parce que c'est un peu compliqué bien
évidemment que lorsqu'on a abouti que
lorsqu'on aboutit une situation de
violence dans une manifestation je ne
considère pas je n'ai jamais considéré
que c'était une réussite jamais jamais
jamais jamais la violence c'est ce qu'il
faut à tout prix éviter justement pour
permettre le droit de manifester donc
toute mon action a visé à cela ma seule
préoccupation dans les manifestations
c'était d'éviter les blessés et d'éviter
ce qui aurait été pour moi une
catastrophe à mort des morts donc
d'éviter
on n'est pas là pour faire le procès de
Monsieur l'allemand on sait pas
l'objectif le rôle de la Commission
d'enquête et d'aller sur sur des
éléments justement factuels et donc on
va laisser répondre et chacun s'exprime
à son tour mais on n'est pas dans un jeu
de ping-pong avec Monsieur l'allemand
ce qui provoque des blessés ce sont
l'attitude de certains manifestants ceux
qui cassent ceux qui attaque ce qui
détruisent c'est ça ce qui provoque les
blessés pensez dans une je vois bien
comment comme le dispositif le
raisonnement si vous me permettez à ces
Manic et un qui est le vôtre
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a violence d'État
on doit répondre en exprimant sa
violence moi je pense pas que ce soit
vrai je vous le dis les yeux dans les
yeux je ne pense pas que ce soit vrai
mais tout l'histoire du maintien de
l'ordre en France et justement fait pour
éviter la violence et les morts
historiquement d'ailleurs le président à
la gentillesse de citer mon ouvrage mais
je rappelle les considérations
historiques qui ont amené à sortir les
militaires du dispositif de maintien de
l'ordre après des massacres terribles
fourmis ensuite après la Première Guerre
mondiale a créé les compagnies les
premières compagnies de CRS enfin
d'escadron de gendarmes mobiles pardon
et après la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais pourquoi par exemple y a-t-il
autant de blessés dans les violences
urbaines qui ont eu lieu il y a quelques
jours beaucoup plus quand 2005 quand on
compare les durées des périodes parce
que Monsieur le Député je suis navré de
vous le dire mais ce pays devenu
infiniment plus violent
que lorsque j'étais jeune c'est à dire
au lendemain de la guerre de 14
voilà c'est tout parce que il y a une
évolution sociale on peut le dire
sociétale qui concourt à la violence
peut-être aussi parce que il y a
aujourd'hui des des influenceurs de la
vie politique et de la vie sociale qui
eux-mêmes appel à la violence peut-être
son sens des réponses moi je n'en sais
rien je ne suis ici qu'un modeste
fonctionnaire c'est à vous les
politiques de vous interroger là-dessus
on va juste passer la parole là monsieur
le rapporteur mais je n'ai pas oublié
monsieur Lucas vous souhaitiez également
intervenir oui merci monsieur le
Président moi je note simplement en tant
que rapporteur
qui devrait être lire par conséquent
compte-rendu de nos travaux vous avez vu
des propos plutôt
modérés plutôt réaliste quand vous dites
par exemple que les stratégies qui
impliquaient d'avoir des groupes de
fonctionnaires statiques étaient plutôt
des points de concentration potentiel de
violence que par conséquent il fallait
faire évoluer le schéma national de
matériaux je pense que c'est plutôt un
constat réaliste lorsque vous indiquez
que il y a une demande de pénalisation
forte dans la société et que la foi
l'interdiction de manifester que nous
proposerons peut-être ou pas
à l'égal de l'interdiction de paraître
pardon dans les dans les stades vous
indiquez qu'il y a la fois des avantages
cette option et puis un certain nombre
d'inconvénients que vous avez soulignés
enfin je note quand même que vos propos
étaient me semble-t-il construit modéré
pas manichéen en tout cas de mon point
de vue ce n'est pas comme ça en tout cas
que je traduirai dans le rapport que je
proposerai à nos collègues une question
sur la vue la judiciarisation pardon
l'un des éléments qui apparaît à
l'occasion de nos auditions c'est la
très grande difficulté
à transmettre la bonne information
à l'officier de police judiciaire puis
bien sûr ensuite au magistrat concernant
la réalité des comportements
constaté lors de l'interpellation de
l'individu violent sur ce point
quels sont les faiblesses que vous avez
pu constater quelles sont les évolutions
que vous suggérez je dis pour
l'éclairage de chacun pour celles et
ceux qui n'étaient pas là toutes les
auditions il y a par exemple je n'en
suis pas très fan donc je dis d'autant
plus que je n'en suis pas très fan il y
a je crois que c'est le représentant de
la CFDT qui proposait la création de bus
d'opgi moi je vois beaucoup
d'inconvénients à cette solution mais je
présenterai des avantages des
inconvénients de cette proposition qui a
été faite dans le rapport de façon
objective et puis nous verrons si nous
pouvons trancher ce point mais sur voilà
quelles sont les constats que vous avez
fait sur la question de l'interpellation
sur la question de la transmission
d'information qui permet de judiciariser
donc de sanctionner et quels sont les
options que vous pensiez utile
proposition de faire à la commission
Monsieur le Préfet
secrétaire général merci monsieur le
Président oui c'est le rapporteur la
judiciarisation
complique singulièrement le dispositif
de maintien de l'ordre pourquoi parce
que comme vous le savez dès lors que
vous interpellez
un manifestant
sur le dont vous avez la preuve qui
vient de commettre une infraction ou un
délit ça immobilise l'équipe qui l'a
fait jusqu'à ce qui arrive le moyen de
transport vers le commissariat pour la
présentation devant le PJ
et donc ça vous immobilise des effectifs
plus vous interpellez plus vos effectifs
sont immobilisés plus il vous faut des
moyens de transport vous évoquiez des
bus mais des norias qui vous permettent
d'aller vers les différents
commissariats pour les présentations aux
EPG et ce qui est l'essentiel il faut
élaborer les PV d'interpellations et
donc il faut que des fonctionnaires de
maintien de l'ordre se mettent à faire
un PV d'un point interpellation sur le
trottoir
décrivant les circonstances
imaginez que ce que ça se passe au
milieu d'un brouhaha voire au milieu de
tension extrême donc il y a des moments
c'est quasi de l'ordre de
l'impossibilité pratique
donc ce que nous faisions lorsque
j'étais en charge c'était que les
équipes qui avaient interpellé sortaient
du dispositif se mettait sur les
arrières pour rédiger le PV et attendre
le moyen de de véhicule
qui pouvait être très long parce que
lorsque on essaye de faire venir un
véhicule au plus près d'une
manifestation c'est assez compliqué les
rues sont bloqués le véhicule ne sait
pas et en plus ensuite il faut qu'il
repartent vers le commissariat Haddock
etc donc c'est vrai qu'une des
faiblesses de la judiciarisation dans
les manifestations et justement en
termes juridique celle-là ce qui
explique beaucoup
qu'il y ait des écarts assez forts entre
les garde à vue
et les suites judiciaires au moment de
la présentation devant le magistrat
voire même pendant la garde vue le péji
de lui-même considère souvent à juste
titre qu'il n'a pas les éléments pour et
ça je crois que de toute façon c'est
constitutif de de ce qu'est cette ce
besoin de pénalisation et ça oblige
aussi à des formations des effectifs
chargés du maintien de l'ordre qui sont
obligés de se former
qui n'ont pas la qualité de PJ qui sont
obligés de se former à tout cela et
c'est là où les les Black Blocs ont une
grande force opérationnelle c'est qu'ils
ont eux parfaitement compris tout ça et
qu'il le maîtrise assez bien
alors est-ce qu'il y a des méthodes oui
n'a pas enfin la méthode que que j'avais
mise en place en famille en place que
nous avions
constitué avec cette immobilisation des
équipes
il faut être très clair quand vraiment
ça se passe très très mal
vous avez tendance à dire que
l'interpellation se fera pas tout de
suite tout de suite donc ensuite vous
avez des enquêtes qui sont ouvertes avec
les caméras qui permettent d'essayer de
tracer telle ou tel individu mais
lorsqu'ils sont assez aguerris
c'est-à-dire qu'ils connaissent les
dispositifs qu'ils savent se changer au
bon endroit
c'est très très difficile et puis
apporter la preuve et trouver des
témoins par exemple je vais prendre
quelque chose de très concret vous avez
une quinzaine d'individus en train de
casser une vitrine
les forces de police interviennent
elles sont immédiatement entourées par
une nuée de photographes
journalistes
de gens avec un smartphone qui les films
qui sont autant d'obstacles à la
visibilité de ce qui se passe il faut
bien concevoir au niveau du terrain vous
le voyez dans les images de
manifestations mais sur le terrain vous
êtes à hauteur d'homme et vous avez un
mur de personnes qui sont comme ça
et qui sont à quelques centimètres du
visage des fonctionnaires et donc ça
vous dissimule complètement votre
capacité d'identification quand bien
même vous arriveriez à identifier
vous avez tout un écosystème qui se met
en place autour et notamment vous avez
énormément de street qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les Street maydhiques c'est
à dire des gens en blanc qui arrivent
et pour peu qu'il y ait une intervention
de police que la personne interpellée
ton baptaire immédiatement vous avez des
tas de gens en blanc qui se précipitent
et qui sont autant d'éléments de
déstabilisation de la visibilité que
vous avez c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas
que les Black Blocs vous avez un
écosystème qui
rend difficile la perception et
l'identification judiciaire
faut voir que
je crois le dire dans mon ouvrage il y a
quelques auxiliaires des dispositifs
voilà mais qui sont très difficiles à
déterminer puisque par définition comme
les Black Blocs ils ne se sont pas
identifiables dans l'ensemble auquel il
prétend d'appartenir voilà et tout ça
rend très difficile l'apport de la
preuve et l'apport de la preuve résulte
souvent de la déclaration des
fonctionnaires mais il est pratiquement
impossible de trouver un autre témoin il
a déclaration des fonctionnaires elle
repose sur en fait
en termes judiciaire ça fonctionne quand
vraiment vous prenez le gars avec le
marteau en train de taper sur la vitrine
là effectivement c'est incontestable
quand un gars a tapé sur la vitrine à la
chaîne marteau et que vous avez une nuée
de moineau que vous l'avez repéré que
vous le prenez
ça va être difficile au plan judiciaire
de dire oui oui c'était bien lui c'est à
dire que le fond les fonctionnaires ou
les militaires l'ont suivi etc sont à
peu près sur deux mais l'apport de la
preuve est quasi impossible à faire donc
faut voir une concrète au ce que tout ça
veut dire
je vais laisser la parole ensuite à
Benjamin Lucas mais de deux questions
dans ce contexte
démontez-vous qu'il y ait eu y compris
lorsque vous assuriez votre fonction
évidemment des stratégies
d'interpellation massive en vue de
déstabiliser
les effectifs violents première question
deuxième question la Ligue des droits de
l'homme
propose la création d'un statut
d'observateur
identifiable identifier dans le champ
des manifestations le statut
d'observateur ayant vocation alors du
point de vue la ligne droite de l'homme
de regarder d'abord le comportement des
forces de l'ordre mais dans mon esprit
ce pourrait être un statut d'observateur
beaucoup plus impartial si j'ose dire
qui regarde absolument tout le contexte
les situations constatées donc au sein
des notamment des prix courtages est-ce
que sur cette sur ce statut
d'observateur vous voyez des
inconvénients est-ce que ça ajoute à cet
écosystème qui rend difficile y compris
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre ou
est-ce que c'est un élément qui peut
participer de ce que certains appellent
une forme de désescalade ou
d'objectivation des phénomènes de
violence à l'occasion des manifestations
des rassemblements
je vous en prie c'est ce qui a été en
général merci monsieur le président
non il y a pas de stratégie
d'interpellation vous interpellez quand
il est nécessaire que vous interpelliez
on part pas dans une manifestation en se
disant on va interpeller x personnes
encore une fois l'interpellation pour
les services de police et pour les
services judiciaires c'est compliqué et
puis n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas je ne
peux pas vous parler comme ça mais c'est
pas fini quand vous avez interpellé
quelqu'un votre journée commence
elle quand la manifestation est finie
commence le processus de suite des
interpellations donc ça veut dire que
dans les SAIP ils vont y passer la nuit
avec malheureusement les interpellés que
pour les magistrats de permanence ils
vont y passer la nuit et une partie de
la journée suivante donc une
interpellation c'est le début de longues
heures de mobilisation d'un dispositif
administratif et judiciaire
pendant que les saïdes sont occupés Saïd
vous savez c'est le dispositif à la PP
de suivi judiciaire quand Saïd est
occupé à faire du traitement de
manifestation il s'occupe pas des autres
affaires judiciaires des autres fêtes
délinquance qui arrivent où ils s'en
occupe moins rapidement donc vous
accroissez vos fils d'attente dans le
traitement judiciaire alors dans les
services de police c'est la principale
difficulté c'est le traitement
judiciaire c'est les suites qu'on donne
et donc vous embolisez votre dispositif
c'est exactement la même chose pour les
magistrats ils embellissent complètement
au niveau des magistrats de permanence
le dispositif donc tout ça pour vous
dire que l'interpellation est très
lourde pour les pour l'ensemble des
services police ou judiciaires et qui a
pas de de stratégie en la matière et à
tout simplement un moment où il le faut
alors après vous je pense que la
question que vous posez elle est liée à
ce qui est aujourd'hui la communication
politique ou effectivement
la communication politique a tendance à
dire il y a eu beaucoup d'interpeller
donc c'est la preuve que le dispositif
va fonctionne bien je le dis c'est pas
le fait de ce gouvernement je
l'observais déjà sur les gouvernements
précédents et même avant
ces deux quinquennat là ça fonctionne ça
a beaucoup fonctionné comme ça
je crois pas que l'interpellation soit
un critère de la réussite ou non d'une
opération de police elle est un élément
qu'il est nécessaire que le public
connaisse parce que il est assez
explicite sur les niveaux de violence
mais ça veut pas dire que c'est une
manifestation qui s'est bien ou mal
passée alors les statues d'observateur
non enfin vous me demandez fort
gentiment monsieur le rapporteur à mon
avis non moi j'y suis pas favorable
on n'a pas besoin dans ce pays
d'observateurs dans nos manifestations
nous ne sommes pas enfin comme l'ONU
peut envoyer des observateurs dans
certains pays enfin nous sommes dans la
République française ou
il y a des manifestants il y a des
autorités il y a des gens qui sont assez
remontés et puis il y a le contrôle de
l'ensemble des journalistes des images
etc mettre en plus au milieu de tout ça
des observateurs mais
ça ne serait plus la République ça
serait
considéré que nous sommes hors du droit
commun et qu'on appliquerait ce qu'on
fait dans des terres lointaines lorsque
les Nations Unies considèrent que les
règles fondamentales des droits de
l'homme ne sont plus respectés mais ça
me heurterait assez profondément
merci beaucoup monsieur Lucas je vous en
prie
les organes des Nations Unies nous
interpellent régulièrement sur le
maintien de l'ordre dans notre pays moi
je vais juste une remarque et une
question une remarque parce que j'étais
assez surpris par vous me pardonnerez le
terme je n'en trouve pas de meilleur la
forme de légèreté avec laquelle vous
avez répondu à Monsieur Caron sur
l'article de Mediapart en disant une
forme de bouteille je ne lis pas
Médiapart ce n'est là aussi de mémoire
ni la ni la Bible ni le Journal Officiel
bon moi le la Bible ne fait pas
nécessairement partie de des lectures
imposées un préfet de la République j'en
conviens aisément comme vous en revanche
je vous conviendrai avec moi que la
presse concours dans une grande
démocratie comme la nôtre à la bonne
information de tous y compris des
autorités publiques et des acteurs
publics ce qui me surprend et peut-être
ce sera ma question c'est qu'un préfet
de police ne serait pas informé parce
que vous personnellement ne soyez pas
abonnés à Mediapart c'est votre liberté
mais que il n'a pas été porté à votre
connaissance officiellement par vos
services comme préfet de police
d'accusation grave
sur des cas de violence policière ça me
paraît assez surprenant et à ses
inquiétants d'ailleurs parce que je
crois que beaucoup dans l'histoire de
notre République vous aviez vous y avez
fait référence la longue histoire
républicaine c'est la presse qui a
permis par des enquêtes et des travaux
beaucoup de révélations qui ont permis à
la République d'avoir de se renforcer et
de et de s'améliorer ma question elle
concerne le
rapport à la tension à la société le
rapport de de tension dans la société
que vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure je
fais pas ici de bataille d'analyses vous
avez évoqué des des appels à la violence
de de dirigeants politiques j'en ai pas
lu entendu mais peut-être n'est-je pas
été assez assidu au même lecture que
vous vous auriez pu sans doute dans
votre intervention faire le lien avec ce
que vous disiez au début de votre propos
quand vous regrettiez la faiblesse
finalement des organisations syndicales
on peut y voir là aussi une orientation
politique depuis un certain nombre
d'années qui conduit à affaiblir les
intermédiaires les organisations
syndicales les mobilisations pacifiques
et donc de fait expliquer n'est pas
excusé mais à entraîner une forme une
forme de violence et je termine d'une
chose vous avez tout à l'heure évoqué
Monsieur le Préfet quand je posais la
question sur le camp républicain ou pas
vous avez dit il y a des gens qui
veulent abattre la République c'est vrai
et vous avez fait référence à une
expression ce qui veut la battre la
gueuse qui vient historiquement
d'ailleurs de de l'extrême droite
nationaliste royaliste dans notre dans
notre pays est-ce que le syndicat de
police Alliance qui dans un communiqué
récent appelle à mettre hors d'état de
nuire des nuisibles qui qualifient
la deuxième fois que vous intervenez
normalement c'est une intervention puis
voilà donc je termine et être au combat
et à exercer une forme de pression sur
le pouvoir exécutif et sur les autorités
dont le préfet de police est-ce que vous
considérez que le syndicat Alliance et
dans le camp républicain ou pas
ce secrétaire général je vous repasse la
parole merci monsieur le Président
écoutez monsieur le député j'ai prêté
serment et donc
[Musique]
je vous ai dit la vérité je ne l'ai pas
Médiapart je vous le redis je voudrais
pas vous dire que je lis Mediapart
puisque je ne le lis pas vous avez l'air
de me le reprocher
je suis très surpris mais je vais mettre
à lire mes dire parte alors si c'est ça
non mais je voulais pas vous dire que je
les Médiapart ce n'est pas média à
partir des choses que je n'ai jamais lu
je ne dis pas ce qui se passe dans les
réseaux je pense que
il faut s'intéresser à ce qui se passe
dans la réalité du monde et pas dans la
tête d'un certain nombre de gens bon
non mais la presse la presse moi je suis
un grand clémentiste donc si vous voulez
je suis persuadé du rôle de la presse et
de son apport fondamental dans
l'histoire de nos républiques
et donc j'ai aucun problème avec la
presse mais
la question de Monsieur Caron tout à
l'heure à moins que je fais les mal
comprises elle portait sur le fait de
savoir
si ce qui était donc relaté par
Mediapart avait été porté à ma
connaissance c'est-à-dire des reproches
faits par des policiers des gendarmes
sur la légalité des dispositifs
alors peut-être que j'ai mal compris
mais j'avais cru comprendre que c'était
ça et puisque vous me reposez cette
question là je le redis je n'ai jamais
eu la moindre note le moindre élément
porté à ma connaissance de d'éléments
oraux Europe enfin faisons état
d'irrégularités résultant des ordres
données voilà d'irrégularité c'est à
dire vous savez que quand même des
règles juridiques qui visent à ne pas
obéir à des ordres illégaux jamais je
n'étais confronté à ça voilà donc je
vous le dis très très directement après
vous comprendrez que je peux pas
répondre sur des choses qui
ne sont pas que je n'ai pas eu à
connaître et notamment la position que
vous évoquez d'un syndicat de police moi
je peux pas vous répondre là dessus je
ne suis plus en responsabilité je
m'occupe des sujets maritimes sur
lesquels j'aurai le plus grand plaisir à
échanger avec vous mais je ne peux
absolument pas commenter des éléments
récents de cette nature
merci beaucoup monsieur Caron pour une
dernière intervention oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Secrétaire
général
vous vendiez tout à l'heure le la
politique française de maintien de
l'ordre qui serait quasi dylique qui
n'utilise la force que lorsque c'est
absolument nécessaire mon collègue Luca
le rappeler nous avons tout de même été
épinglé par un certain nombre
d'observateurs internationaux
notamment le Conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'ONU mais peut-être sont-ils
de parti pris et peut-être
n'observe-t-il pas bien les choses
vous me reprochiez de faire référence à
des cas qui n'étaient pas suffisamment
précis pour vous permettre de nous
livrer une analyse qui serait pertinente
vous semblez découvrir aujourd'hui des
éléments dont vous n'aviez jamais
entendu parler vous ne saviez pas quand
vous avez reproché votre boutique de
maintien de l'ordre qu'on l'a jugé
violentes qu'on l'a jugé responsable
d'un certain nombre de problèmes dans
les manifestations donc bah écoutez vous
aurez donc appris quelque chose ce matin
donc puisque vous le saviez pas les
gilets jaunes c'est des centaines de
manifestants blessés à la tête par des
terres de LBD une trentaine des borniers
vous lis un cas précis ça va être ma
question monsieur le Président il y a
pas de cas précis manuel Quan nous
sommes le samedi 16 novembre 2019
manifestation donc tout est calme nous
sommes Place d'Italie manuel Quan et
statique sur la Place d'Italie ils
discute avec d'autres manifestants et il
reçoit un tiers de LBD dans l'oeil et il
sera donc ébornier il ne représentait
aucun danger il était parfaitement
pacifique et c'est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres que je pourrais vous donner qui
ont été documentés par cette presse que
vous le lisez jamais
et avec apparemment des gens dans votre
entourage qui ne sont pas non plus
informés et qui ne vous disent rien donc
il y a deux solutions vous l'avez
rappelé vous êtes sous serment donc soit
réellement vous avez
comment dirais-je remplir vos fonctions
dans des conditions qui m'interrogent
c'est à dire en parfaite méconnaissance
de ce qui se passait sur le terrain soit
et là ce sera assez grave vous avez sous
serment menti
donc je vous repose la question est-ce
que vous continuez à nier devant nous
sous serment que lorsque vous étiez en
fonction
des violences gratuites et non
nécessaires ont été commises par des
forces de l'ordre contre des
manifestants
très bien je vais évidemment passer la
parole à Monsieur l'allemand je rappelle
simplement pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien que le périmètre
temporaire de notre commission 16 mars
2023 3 mai 2023 donc voilà le délai
temporaire et donc encore une fois vous
faites référence à un fait qui date de
2019 il n'est pas dans le périmètre de
notre commission
il me semble que ça l'est puisque nous
nous interrons sur des pratiques qui
peut-être ont toujours cours aujourd'hui
très bien mais je laisse je laisse la
parole à Monsieur l'allemand
non mais malheureusement monsieur le
Président malheureusement je ne peux que
que
confirmer ce que vous évoquez et dire à
Monsieur le Député Caron que
le
cas qui l'évoque est un cas couvert par
une instruction judiciaire que je ne
peux absolument pas commenter vous le
comprendrez ça serait contraire au
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
quant aux observateurs internationaux
oui j'ai effectivement entendu récemment
puisqu'il m'arrive de lire des journaux
les condamnations de l'Algérie et de
l'Iran je vous le confirme
très bien ben écoutez merci beaucoup je
vous propose de clore cette audition en
vous renouvelant nos remerciements
Monsieur le Secrétaire général Monsieur
le Chef de Cabinet je vais suspendre la
séance pendant quelques minutes le temps
de permettre aux auditionnés suivants de
prendre la place éventuellement pour
certains collègues de prendre un café à
tout de suite merci beaucoup